l'instant dites-vous est assez grave
mais serein on se pose plus la question
morale à ce moment le débat a déjà eu
lieu on est on accompagne la personne
jusqu'au bout mais en même temps je
pense que son ce sont les gestes à la
fois les plus lourds et sans doute les
plus les plus profonds que l'on peut
poser par rapport à quelqu'un qui vous
fait une telle demande
ce soir le Docteur Dominique le signal
bonsoir
alors le 12 août dernier le médecin
urgentiste de l'hôpital de Bayonne
Nicolas Bonnemaison a été mis en examen
pour empoisonnement sur personne
particulièrement vulnérables il est
soupçonné d'avoir euthanasié 7 personnes
il risque la prison à perpétuité avec
nous ce soir donc le Docteur Dominique
le signal vous aussi vous pratiquez
l'euthanasie mais vous ne risquez pas la
prison car vous êtes belge tout à fait
voilà
[Musique]
docteur le signal rebondoir donc
aujourd'hui le tanazi est autorisé dans
deux États de l'Union européenne les
Pays-Bas et la Belgique en Suisse il y a
un autre système qui s'appelle le
suicide assisté et j'ajouterai le
Luxembourg aussi
c'est parce que vous êtes belle donc que
vous pouvez pratiquer le tennis chez
vous oui alors vous êtes né le 23
janvier 1960 à Soignies en Wallonie perd
dessinateur industriel maire employée de
bureau vous êtes élevé dans une ambiance
douce et chaleureuse
et ce bonheur familial et nappé d'une
culture de l'engagement et du courage
insufflé par vos deux grands-pères qui
ont été résistants de la première heure
contre les nazis alors ces récits ont du
forgé votre esprit de résistance c'est
peut-être la succession dans la famille
qui qui se voit comme cela sous une
façon de voir les choses en effet
étude sans problème jusqu'à un diplôme
de docteur en médecine à l'âge de 25 ans
vous vous spécialisez là dans la
cancérologie alors dès vos premiers mois
d'internat au service d'oncologie vous
prenez conscience de l'intérêt de
traiter la douleur différemment ne
serait-ce qu'avec de la morphine
c'est-à-dire qu'à l'époque les gens s'en
foutaient que les patients souffrent
terriblement et on se contentait de ce
qu'on de ce qu'on avait on ne cherche
pas trop à améliorer la situation mais
il y avait pas de formation il y avait
pas vraiment un intérêt pour cela à
l'époque les toubibs disaient quand on
traite la maladie on traite la douleur
il disait le traitement de la douleur
c'est un boulot de feignant et en
parlant de la morphine il disait que
c'était le traitement du dealer ça va
mauvaise presse effectivement on m'a on
m'a traité dealer parce que je donnais
de la morphine à des patients qui avait
mal donc c'est un je dirais que
l'histoire m'a donné tort à ces
personnes là et m'a donné raison enfin
nous a donné raison en 1988 vous partez
aux États-Unis à Baltimore pour une
formation d'un an justement dans le
traitement de la douleur qui est un
sujet qui vous intéresse beaucoup et là
vous voyez qu'il y a des équipes
d'infirmières qui sont chargés de
surveiller la douleur des malades il y a
des échelles de douleur et les médecins
on parle avec leur patients et puis vous
découvrirez aussi de nouvelles molécules
plus efficaces que la morphine et c'est
vrai que on avait l'impression de
découvrir un nouveau monde en arrivant
alors après deux ans aux USA vous êtes
reconnus donc comme spécialiste en
cancérologie c'est vrai que dans les
services de cancérologie la probabilité
de rencontrer des malades qui demandent
au médecin de les aider à mourir et plus
grande que par tout ailleurs évidemment
c'est normal alors ça vous arrive
une femme atteinte dans le cancer
gynécologique vous demande de l'aider à
mourir
vous décidez de le faire malgré le
risque d'être considéré comme un
criminel par les autorités belges car à
l'époque la loi belge est identique à la
loi française aujourd'hui donc on sait
très bien à l'époque le risque que l'on
court même si on pratique on pose le
geste dans les meilleures conditions
possibles pour la personne en respectant
sa demande sa dignité en ayant les
entretiens nécessaires alors d'abord
vous voyez la famille pour vous assurer
que tout le monde est d'accord
c'est-à-dire qu'à l'époque il y avait
une sorte d'omerta comme vous l'avez dit
on ne pouvait pas en parler en tout cas
aussi librement que maintenant mais a
priori on voulait être certain qu'il n'y
aurait évidemment pas de délation qu'il
n'y aurait pas ensuite un une
déclaration à la police de la part d'un
mort la famille qui serait pas au
courant donc mais toutes les discussions
par rapport à la décision de la personne
et de la patiente en particulier c'était
fait dans sa présence donc il n'y avait
pas il n'y avait pas de faux fouillant
la personne s'exprimait devant sa
famille parce qu'après vous aurez des
cas où la famille se dispute devant vous
et là vous dites attendez on fait rien
du tout vous dit qu'il y a pas d'urgence
à mourir non plus donc quand vous sentez
que tout le monde
[Musique]
l'instant dites-vous est assez grave
mais serein on se pose plus la question
morale à ce moment le débat a déjà eu
lieu on est on accompagne la personne
jusqu'au bout mais en même temps je
pense que son ce sont les gestes à la
fois les plus lourds et sans doute les
plus les plus profonds que l'on peut
poser par rapport à quelqu'un qui vous
fait une telle demande donc très souvent
les malades dites-vous disent merci
avant de partir ils disent merci ou
enfin ils font leurs adieux il faut une
déclaration particulière mais c'est
toujours dans un climat de remerciement
et c'est assez impressionnant il faut le
il faut le reconnaître alors le soir de
ce jour-là donc vous posez pas mal de
questions évidemment vous dites ce que
je vais pas en prison d'abord parce que
c'était à l'époque en Belgique
absolument illégal est-ce que je n'ai
pas transgressé une loi divine c'est sûr
qu'on peut pas me passer la question
et puis vous n'avez pas respecté le
serment d'Hippocrate ce qui pour un tout
libre est quand même un problème c'est
vrai qu'on se réfère souvent en serment
d'Hippocrate je vous inviterai à le lire
une fois dans son intégralité pour vous
rendre compte à quel point on serait
faire à un texte traditionnel qui ne
rencontre plus du tout la réalité
médicale actuelle il interdit beaucoup
de choses que le que le médecin
maintenant fait ne fut-ce que les
avortements ne fût-ce que le fait
d'inciser un patient est interdit
d'enterrement d'Hippocrate je crois que
c'est un petit peu un petit peu facile
de s'y référer alors qu'en même temps on
le transgresse depuis des siècles et la
transgression de la loi divine ça vous
impose un problème non et c'est surtout
grâce à des patients croyants que que je
me pose la question n'étant pas croyant
moi-même
certains patients croyants expliquent
pourquoi ils vont demander une
euthanasie et que ça ne l'aimait pas en
porte-à-faux avec leurs croyances je
crois que dans le texte biblique on
trouve pas mal de traces de d'aide à
mourir par compassion et je crois que
que si vous allez au fond des choses
aider un malade en lui évitant une mort
atroce ou des souffrances une agonie
pénibles ça va tout à fait dans le sens
du discours chrétien papa pourquoi il
faudrait que les gens subitement se
mettent à souffrir et à bonne idée
agoniser dans des situations impossible
la dimension doloriste du christianisme
ça oui qui n'a pas qui ne transparaît
pas dans les dans les textes originaux
alors vous vient à ce moment-là cette
question qui est fondamentale est-ce que
le poids que le malade doit supporter
quotidiennement et plus léger que le
poids de ma conscience donc je crois
qu'il faut il faut trouver cet accord ce
cheminement que l'on fait ensemble et
même si le geste est difficile et le
malade et moi-même le savon et on agit
en conséquence mais je ne voudrais pas
me dire j'ai la conscience tranquille je
l'ai laissé mourir sans intervenir c'est
très beau ce que vous dites c'est très
fort en tous les cas
alors un an après ce jour-là donc la
famille viendra à nouveau vous dire
merci et vous dira finalement le deuil a
été peut-être plus facile que que ce qui
croyait tu sais c'est beaucoup plus
facile à accepter son départ qui était
inéluctable qu'une mort dans des
conditions malsaines inconfortables ou
mort violente d'une manière ou d'une
autre
voilà donc ça c'est le premier cas
auquel vous avez été confronté et puis à
la fameuse affaire Jean-Marie Laurent
donc il y avait 51 ans qui vit depuis
l'âge de 9 ans avec la maladie de
Charcot donc une dégénérescence
neuromusculaire incurable le condamnant
à mort par étouffement alors que son
esprit reste intacte et vous vous dites
en fait il se noyait dans son propre
corps c'était quelque chose qu'il que
l'on peut lire dans un bouquin de
médecine on l'accepte on dit OK et quand
on est sur place on se dit là c'est
quand même une autre problématique je
dirais un sujet que la plupart des gens
qui condamnaient sa demande ne sont
jamais venus le voir alors c'était un
peu facile à distance de dire ce
monsieur devrait de vrais bénéficier de
telle soit il devrait faire ceci ou cela
quand on ne voit la personne devant soi
c'est un peu c'est un peu différent
quand même d'ailleurs il avait écrit un
livre qui s'appelait aidez-moi à mourir
donc voilà ça sans disait long sur sa
volonté réelle alors il vous appelle lui
veut en finir tout de suite mais là une
demande en dehors de l'hôpital donc ça
vous semble impossible à réaliser vous
allez le voir et quand vous le voyez
vous voyez bien effectivement que la
situation est inhumaine donc en prenant
contact avec ses proches vous comprenez
que tout le monde est d'accord pour
abréger ses souffrances et il ne manque
que le médecin et ça sera vous alors le
8 juillet 2000 donc vous vous rendez
discrètement donc chez Jean-Marie
Laurent avec dans votre mallette de la
morphine et du curare en fait c'est une
overdose de morphine que vous lui faites
quoi avec convenu qu'il allait avaler
lui-même le produit létal et donc on lui
avait fourni une dose létale de morphine
qu'il a avalé à l'aide d'une paille il
ne pouvait pas tenir le gobelet donc il
a réellement démontré sa volonté de
d'ingérer le tout jusqu'au bout c'était
pas très bon Mathilde dit et puis j'ai
attendu qu'il s'endorme définitivement
mais Jean-Marie Laurent était relié à un
système d'alerte médicale qui signale
mort suspecte alors là le parquet ouvre
une instruction judiciaire il y a un
emballement médiatique sans précédent
vous devenez le médecin le plus
recherché de Belgique à ce moment-là
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir de des amis et
de pouvoir rencontrer un avocat Maître
l'Allemand qui qui s'est présenté en mon
nom devant le juge d'instruction pour
éviter que je sois incarcéré puisque
j'étais évidemment sous le coup d'une
accusation d'abord assassinations en
tout cas je risque cela et donc on a
convenu avec le juge de d'instructions à
ce moment-là que je serai entendu sans
que les médias soient prévenus etc alors
au bout de quelques jours donc vous
allez voir le juge et ce qui est
terrible c'est que pendant votre
audition qui a duré plusieurs heures à
un moment c'est tellement poignant que
le greffier se met à pleurer en plein
milieu alors vous ressortez libre vous
êtes quand même tombé sur un juge oui
j'en suis extrêmement reconnaissant
parce que il m'a dit vous êtes libre ça
voulait dire que j'aurais pu ne pas
l'être deux ans plus tard le Parlement
belge en terrine la dépénalisation de
l'euthanasie grâce à vous je vais pas
dire ça je ne crois pas je pense que
c'est un mouvement qui était plus
général je dirais que c'est surtout
aussi ce qui a pu aider c'est la
sincérité qu'on avait dans le débat pour
dire clairement les choses alors vous
dites la nuit précédent une euthanasie
est toujours chargée d'émotion il faut
se préparer psychologiquement donc c'est
pas c'est pas un acte neutre évidemment
c'est certainement l'acte médical le
plus lourd qu'on puisse poser en termes
de en termes de sentiments il faut quand
même dire les choses telles qu'elles
sont on ne peut pas on ne peut pas faire
l'impasse et après une euthanasie vous
avez besoin de vous isoler aussi vous
avez vos rituels quoi une fois que le
geste est posé que le décès constaté
qu'on a on a salué la famille moi
personnellement j'ai besoin d'un peu un
peu d'espace alors quand on vous dit
combien de gens avez-vous euthanasif du
jeu c'est pas le problème contrairement
à toutes les autres actes médicaux en
général on aime bien dire j'en ai j'ai
pratiqué autant d'interventions j'ai
rencontré autant autant de malades et en
cette maladie dans le cas présent je
pense que le nombre n'a pas d'importance
il y a aucune raison de faire de de
s'autoproclamer le meilleur
euthanasateur
je pense que aucun médecin ne le ferait
très bien merci beaucoup merci merci de
votre témoignage docteur merci et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu